this week's spectator cover is all about
smartphones and memory so we decided to
give some James's Park to find out more
so can you remember what you had for
lunch yesterday
yes we had a toast on an old toast we
cheese tomato that's it well lunch
yesterday I know we have a snack for
lunch I just had some cheese rolls
yeah ham and cheese sandwich and pack of
the quavers do you know any phone
numbers of my heart
my father says provide X is getting
quite old now and strike anyone I can
remember only my mum know we're Spanish
all we know like respondus emergency
numbers you know I was going to say that
I do know the numbers but I if I have to
say it then I would say in Spanish yeah
do you think that having a smartphone
affects your memory at all either a
short-term or long-term so I think it
affects it gives us reason not to
memorize I think that's for sure
I think it does yes because I don't need
to him so much now that was in the past
special things like that they're all
done for you
yeah definitely I think I don't have to
remember stuff cuz I can just rely necks
I know I could look it up like people on
my phone or anything because I don't
remember person's phone numbers I can't
remember address because I looking to
ask them things like that
it helps and they mainly distract me
from doing um I think even if I had like
a paper map if you want to find out more
pick up a copy of this week spectator
out on Thursday